hello everybody and welcome back to
let's play dead space - okay I just
popped in through that door because the
save point was up there so you didn't
miss anything except some birds flying
through the doors I went in sexually got
a surprising that there are actual birds
here like look that's a real ah birdy
can I shoot it onto them I probably can
but I'm not gonna anyway oh that's
cousin his shadow anyway whoever lived
here likes birds and there's this creepy
lady here he said something about
unauthorized access yeah
please step away from the duel whoa
hello BAM you killed yourself oh you're
such an ineffective monster this got
really really like birds apparently all
right what there's a star here star give
me oh goodness
I forget what I
just those cell yeah money okay I'm
running out of plasma energy but it's
okay
pull one of these over I love her I
could probably afford some power notes
two of them should do okay I'm in good
situation with money I'm in a good
situation
ammo relatively across all my guns hey
Macy um DNA identity scan required okay
um didn't open so I can't stasis it oh
oh that's log uh-huh pressure log Howard
Phillips I want to go home anti claims
she didn't get a response to my transfer
request but it's the fifth one how could
there be five requests and no response
surely someone is getting them someone
is reading them I hate to admit it but
the loneliness up here is really more
intense than I expected I think it's
starting to affect me the only good news
is that anti claims to have authorized
my shipment request but they're supposed
to be arriving later today but I can't
believe anything she's dead she tells me
I've been asking for so long it's hard
to believe that might actually let me
have my Birds time will tell tonight
will tell actually okay so that's why he
has his birds up here because man he's
got a lot of birds four Birds a Tron I
am getting fed I know birdy
okay um dartboard dead body what killed
him
um
I can't go back this door locked behind
me when I came in this crazy woman just
followed me enough a crazy computers Oh
what's up their power paranoid room how
do we get up there
hello lady
okay those boxes no um gotta be a way up
um saw the room up there it would suck
to just be up here all alone nice of you
though cuz I'm always wary of windows
that go to outer space cuz you know one
crack and you're done for
umm ha take that um Oh DNA scan DNA
WOB come here ene I'll play it haha
thank you yes
the headless corpse is Howard Phillips
all right come here Howard
come you're Howard stay there for a
second ah
oh I've Howard
knew how and Philip crazy bird man don't
worry
all right power or how it's like don't
worry Isaac I'll take care of all these
mines for you are they yellow
I want my mines to be yellow where you
go Howard oh there you are
all right Howard I lost you come on
Howie coming with me ah ah where'd you
come from
where did he come from
I'm a pity okay um I got some Robles
Oh firestick anyone else babies is a
grenade under ah ah come on ah damn it
damn it
yeah suck on that
okay so I shouldn't have that gun out
when this happens
ah oh no it's gone so scared there we go
what babies
haha - baby goddamn it give me your baby
buddy ah hung on that there you go
I didn't kill you oh there we go ah no
anymore
and these are creepy huh thank you
okay switch over to the javelin what's
in their power grid how do I get up
stairs to that I heard something I don't
get upstairs to that power no room
dramatic music text log mm Oh Howard
Phillips again I've been trying to stay
out of range of ant eyes interfaces as
much as I can I don't want her to hear I
don't want to hear her excuses about any
more about my transfer request every
time I ask I just get computerized
[ __ ] 23 requests I put in 23
requests and not one response I know
she's lying I know she never sent them
I showed auntie though I let all my
birds out of their cages at lunch it was
beautiful
they were all flying around free and
happy and I wish I could be them auntie
was spouting regulations and talking
about abnormal profiles I didn't care I
danced with the birds all day I love my
Birds I want to go
okay is it what is Howard Howard
Phillips reminds me of like the guy from
sub the Big Bang Theory how do you guys
watch that show last name
stop Phillips is it Oh super pro watch
yes uh-huh
there we go sarcone a [ __ ] yeah yeah
huh what ha ha [ __ ] you
been shot
suck on that I know you know Wow
Pepe zapping that that's effectively I
know you don't fall yeah
not that detonator mine
not that not yo anyone else get seong-ho
up here up here get us up here
des go ah
I don't miss Brown here hey how can they
survive outside it's like really cold
out there I mean in Dead Space 1 I froze
one of those things and outside it's you
know pretty freakin cold whatever
javelin gun I think I'm gonna keep that
piece of damage of the all fire damage
is 50 points it's a lot okay whatever
that shot speed welding what do they
mean by speed how fast I can fire it
alright whatever and I got one for that
power node room right over there
who wants them I see you yeah here big
giant thing whatever the heck that was
there we go haha hello
uh-huh
yeah that's likely to happen ah come on
poop oh no back here fine
ah my back here it's like forever ago
pan what happens if I take away these
explosion
hi doesn't do anything
I got me oh I've had enough of death
yeah oh oh yeah bounine get some ha ha
the berries oh the glass didn't break ha
ha I'm smart
alright I'm back here gosh golly talk
about lost progress
I guess it wasn't that far but still
come on tax log yeah blah blah blah
everything
gimme yes yes parish I'm Pro okay
javelin gun cuz one's gonna pop up right
in front of me
oh ah Wow
ah damn
use your gun numbers I hate the javelin
I hate it No
okay
okay okay I'm okay I'm okay
um I'm dandy I'm just so happy right now
and now I'm out of time I gotta go back
in shape oh yes son of up are you yo no
anyway thank you all so much for
watching hope you enjoy that I'll see
you in the next part
oh my